first things first what the heck
comments if comments weren't bad enough
already
I'm sure you've seen it my audience
decided hey let's make them worse
everything is quotes quotes quote Felix
Felix Felix said this PT pi said this
it's all quotes PD PI 2019
it started yeah it started when I was in
Japan I don't know if it's from my
videos but if I had to guess it must
have been from the ifriqiya creeper
comment I said it once okay I take it
back I changed my mind I've seen this
disease spreading to other channels Jack
said the same thing is happening to him
it's all quotes now Sean said this Felix
said this 2019 if you're gonna spam
something annoying on other channels can
you at least do it so that people come
back and watch my channels like all
those other cancer youtubers I come out
of nowhere because they're annoying dumb
ass fan out audience spam surf it
everywhere yes I'm talking about leafy
owned owned now the second problem that
I have is this meme why aborted go away
smoothies be like okay find that one
what it's funny but you're not gonna get
me twice this is the why by the way or
all the intro leave your intros
episode of why I made a water she boss
fight as requested by thousands of new
gamers and Pierce himself McMackin Stein
has done it and I can't wait to play it
finally some fresh content from
minecraft series I think I needed Satan
the guy running Satan account on Twitter
Thank You Satan very cool now wait what
I haven't gone to this episode yet I
don't know where this photo is from
we're in like season six or something
Felix English during its abuse Felix
English in his channel it is evolving
just backwards Full HD so you can enjoy
better well how do you do that that's
magnificent that is HD Wow I didn't know
it was possible to love a photo even
more incredible this is like Felix in
his own channel Felix on other people's
content get it cuz my quality is so bad
remember that meme not anymore gamers
Chris pristine quality you can see the
smudges of my mirror thing next week
did it work if you're a gamer girl and
once free upload then this clearly works
how many up votes 60,000 free up votes
is by the merch it works not if you're a
guy though come on don't be ridiculous
no one wants to see a guy for one night
all cry it's legal Sprint's through area
three years ago wow the gamer as well
what true gamer Wow
you're about three years too early is
that Gwyneth Paltrow I've always
wondered who is that earth must be like
there it is congratulations for
uploading this god dammit now we just
need to see how it looks like from this
position in this position and we finally
can put an end to this meme whoever this
guy is I think it's from Giant Bomb
please let it be over please
I beg you the most illegal thing I own
no you should have posted out on the
item subreddit that's perfect a lot of
things you can do with that rod or that
powerful
that's a freak
I make it a trick joke first guy to buy
a nickel must Scott Devitt oh god we did
this meme last year why is it sad so
confused confused Swedish noises yell PL
I just got engaged men that's sick a peg
yeah keep making bad jokes popular
that's way better damn look at me I look
kind of cute they did it they did the
meme that's beautiful ten out of ten
next time I'm in a suit I'm gonna I'll
make it better first guy to eat the
carrot must have been like this is like
a Bugs Bunny reference oh he sees better
because of carrots well I see in the
dark now I can see the co2 emissions the
her mom said it I think she can see
carbon dioxide with a naked eye
she sees how it flows out of chimneys
and changes the atmosphere in a landfill
that's is so cool thanks mom lucky my
parents have nothing to be proud of so
there's no way they can embarrass me
like that
PT PI it before minecraft vs. PewDiePie
I finished the series and everyone's
like I preferred with the series before
like what am I gonna do
my mom my lunchbox 6 year old me ham
shaped like a teddy bear well luckily I
didn't have parents that prepared meal
for me so I can't relate to this me rich
boy school included lunch meal included
in school we even had a menu but no one
liked the school lunch anyway so we
would just go and buy pizza for lunch
marceia finally figures out all of felix
freak fantasies Felix there is another
it's funny because it's so freakin
accurate here it is again nice I know
someone probably made this but I try my
best
sorry if you are
this the one I saw before was better
here I'll fix it for you so you don't
feel bad there you go done you have to
match the same color grading you dumb
stinky brainer nothing gets through this
armor one day minecraft will have his
life's update what Mike come on it's in
the hands of Microsoft you think those
bastards are gonna let that game die nah
I don't think so
how about this one day pity pie it's
gonna do is last brofist
oh wait I'd already dead get rekt noobs
why am I so min today oh my god I'm so
savage girl oh I love nature me I love
nature to nature good loves nature
nature's done nothing to me I think all
this what does nature done to me huh
what am i a bunch of trees three in the
way it's annoying I said it I know
everyone's too afraid to say it nature
kind of annoying
I believe in global warming and all that
stuff I just don't like the environment
you know it's got outer jump
why on God's earth would you want that
huzzah a man of quality I think any a
man of common sense would rather be the
case just like anyone else wouldn't like
trees if they had common sense when fans
see Felix in public whoa feet where is
this rug I understand now Enderman like
take baths and that's normal
no way they don't oh I got it they don't
like water if they go in the water
they'll get crazy I knew that from the
start next me Wi-Fi drops down one bar
YouTube video quality yeah it's pretty
accurate oh god here we go again
pewds when he sees this make for the
million types so you know huh so you
know how much this pains me well I'm
glad I'm glad you deliberately want to
torture me you're so evil no wonder I
mean to you me sees there is another
meme ready to Scrolls later there is
another I saw one that was really funny
I sent to Jack with the potato one well
maybe it comes up later Frank an
ultimate two Frick
but it's less offensive but off
still satisfying using casual
conversation rather than genuine anger
it is less versatile than the real
f-word and is not used to refer what
that's un-freakin'-believable
I never seen such BS in my life whoever
wrote this you'll be sorry
cuz I'm gonna prick you ah ah ah that is
really cutting it to get to fraud come
on Danny
sword made sound Jake Paul your white
ten-year-olds got iPhones now you'd be
out of a job if they did it that is
absolute savagery unleashed
please take this sword please accept
never understand why they make toys that
make sound for children I thought the
point is to make children less noisy and
less annoying here here's a machine to
make you more annoying here take this
all right I'm 30 years old and I I keep
saying I'm 30 I'm not 30 yet I'm just
preparing myself mentally first guy to
bring drink G fuel must probably been
like levitation night vision false
advertisement but yes it does do that
the new PewDiePie flavor comes out
Wednesday all right you can sign up so
you get notified to make sure that you
get your G fuel on that day all right do
you want to see in the dark do you want
to grow a large penis by the G feel
those two might not coincide but who
knows you don't know if you don't try in
Bing bong
PewDiePie saying he would freak water
for being thick might say being 55
minecraft biome Porter's be like no
that's not funny sorry time to time to
go dog oh but my family didn't come back
yet and I don't think they'd win I'm so
cold
oh let's wait the five more minutes just
kill the dog it's a joke me give
standing ovation
after watching Joker my mom who's been
pushing my wheelchair
for the last 20 years finally a movie
for gamers I can finally go to a movie
with a bunch of virgins and in cells and
I can bring my wife
it's the ultimate power move I can be
like hey guys it's possible
I got gamer girlfriend yes I'm a gamer
no I'm not a virgin I can say it loud
and clear in front of an audience if you
ever feel useless
remember that PewDiePie used a
microphone to hold a mother Michael ah
stop bullying I am NOT used okay alright
alright okay cool
how about this this better are you happy
now huh this is what happens when gamers
get mad we hurt people and I'm gonna go
ahead and say it
video games causes violence alright and
I feel very violent right now so don't
can mess with me brah
I'll cue up it why am i swearing so much
stop guy who said the joke yeah it's big
brain time guy said the joke but better
mark I appreciate you but the big brain
time makes no sense it puts it in the
wrong context you say big brain after
you've done something that's big brain
saying it's big brain time implies that
it hasn't occurred yet when you say it's
big brain time it's like I'm gonna do
something really dumb but if you say it
then it's not my brain it's not big
enough to explain this okay
minecraft here it's episode 1 - 30
episode 31 to 34 let's freakin rise up
and go beyond gamers yeah I play Skyrim
yeah I own a Nintendo switch that was
something on my floor I just picked it
up because it was dirty and 67 levels
dies doesn't lose levels I'm gonna
pretend I didn't see that good keep it
that way
I saw a bunch of comments being hey poot
you should introduce commit I'll do that
[Music]
I think I chucked down the G fuel a
little too quickly I'm sorry gamers oh
that's a really hot girl right there
damn that's some sexy gamer girl action
right there
nice nice check out the March I just
washed my hair
do you ever hate when you wash your hair
and it looks way too tidy that's better
Felix I hate false advertising Felix
talking about cheap oh so I said it I
didn't even remember I said that it
gives you night vision levitation
big peepee big brain small brain as well
if you want when Gloria Borger there's
nothing bad about PewDiePie oh really
that's pretty good that's pretty clever
I like that
that's a good joke when your mom gets
you ready for the first day of school
this is so sweet
those hats were freaking late I spoke
about this today I had one and I pray to
God every day that I find it again
because that actually gave you a
levitation you spin that you fly fly
they don't sell them anymore why that
should be merged yeah when you don't
have any ideas for your Minecraft
single-player episodes so you go to
Japan to avoid making them big brain
while I came back and things happen you
as town reject solar farm emits worries
it would suck up all the energy from the
Sun I mean if they could do that then
Jesus Christ they're being awesome
stop swearing fun fact even if you're
not in a warm countries solar panels
still work because it's the UV light not
the heat the more you know gamers girls
listening to Billy Elish boys listening
to Jews world gamers watching Joker
nine-year-olds watching Felix minecraft
series it is a true tragedy that's all
that's a second when will you understand
that there are only two genders farmers
workers this joke is transphobic and
sexist and communist sticks so I'm
moving on me buying coke and mentos at
the store cashier something's wrong
buying toilet paper and eggs at store I
remember doing that you might you have
to buy eggs Emily we should probably buy
something else to buy a porn magazine
yeah that's like suspicious good job
fillies I would owe this place that the
porn magazine with the cover down think
thinking that they wouldn't turn it over
yeah they'll just beat the code that's
on the back my fight drops down by one
bar YouTube quality well god damn it now
I can't even wear my beret anymore what
am I gonna do when I wash my hair and it
looks way too proper don't like yank
it's too long is what I don't have time
to go hairdresser and then they're gonna
go hey so what do you do for a living I
didn't make videos oh my god my Baba
it's tough I know it's tough being me if
I find animal the video ends and
PewDiePie's channel it's the other way
around
when beautifies sees an animal the
animal ends that is so offensive I
cannot believe this
angry Swedish noises threatens to hurt
you with violence only I self-defense
but I will murder you the stuff this
will be the last thing you see before
you die just to be clear we kicking X to
close out of an ad the ex being part of
the ad I feel like I'm missing out on a
very important piece of culture by not
washing the Joker film yet and it's
pissing me off I think that's why I'm so
on edge today I think that's why I'm so
happy I haven't seen the film yet it did
it doesn't feel it doesn't feel good the
next rocket is going to be powered by
April well then it sure will levitate
like no nothing else before my god every
time I take sip of G fuel glug glug glug
glug Bing bong Bing Bing bong world and
clearly very violent I could see me
kills babies on me with my errands or
everyone party good me nice I enjoyed
that one
they made me laugh I don't know why I
had to reiterate reiterate that after
laughing but yes thank you bros
so much 400 subscribers blank space 12
hour livestream one hundred million
subscribers
see this is another form of this meme
where it's like oh you close your eyes
for a second and then a lot of time
passes it just it's the meme that keeps
on going there's just too many ways to
use a face these pictures of shaggy from
scooby-doo movie makes me so nostalgic
the hair is like on point it's pretty
crazy if the villagers are freaking this
is such an old image are this like long
cat level of what about long cat or what
about ceiling cats
I love this sticking on I am actually
dumbest here this piers come here Jack
Jack I don't wanna you'll just set me on
a trap piers there is potato
let's give me a bit make me laugh it
made me go haha ABCD efg hijk LMNOP does
that work in Swedish obviously the yeah
yeah boi eco element OPA oh yeah I guess
I don't know why I thought it would be
different
big R a joker social media posts are
being monitored by the FBI that frog is
simple oh god he's making symbols ah
he said well Isaac oh god he showed
someone else's name on this video oh god
oh oh that's you dummy dams Felix in
episode 1 Felix episode 8
studying this is brilliant browsing
mindlessly through reddit but I like
this who looks at studying and says this
is brilliant what the tree
I died in one minute and 15 seconds
amateurs what was that Punk and Rajesh
Ingmar rest in peace Ingmar we're all
thinking about you our thoughts and
prayers headphones with wires have saved
tons of phone screens from smashing onto
the ground that's true actually and so
have my foot for kicking it right before
it hits the ground so applause your feet
oh god wait no in hundred days windows 7
will have its last update forcing us to
switch to Windows 10 don't care I can't
believe Jurgen died this is actually on
point because of the last episode oh god
spoilers
no homo not delivered Oh God Pete if I
role-playing be like why would the
Council of Watership do this
I can't believe Council of what their
sheep Oh God
pity fairness bit about YouTube being
around do you like yeah I don't know why
you calling is so good and be like I
don't understand rere other oh there it
is
thank you I needed a haircut god damn
the summer it is so popular now like I
don't have time to even review the top
stuff the entire wrong classroom the
entire class yeah I think I've seen this
all right gamers thanks for watching
another episode sorry things got a
little heated but I think we're cool now
right we're cool at bay it's much like
if you enjoyed and keep watching the
video for an important announcement
everyone clicks out of the video at the
end I see the dropout rate and just stay
because March you gotta buy the large
represent higher ad wait ha well you
haven't tried to persuade me later
citizen II after 50 million our troops
fetch down just now it's still relevant
just down a bit